richard von weizsäcker war vielleicht
der beste bundespräsident in deutschland
je hatte er starb 2015 mit 94 jahren
sein jüngster sohn fritz von weizsäcker
wurde dagegen nur 59 jahre alt aus dem
leben gerissen niedergestochen in aller
öffentlichkeit und jetzt ist auch sein
mörder tod leblos aufgefunden in einer
zelle unter rätselhaften umständen es
gibt bislang keine offizielle erklärung
aber es gibt exklusive neuigkeiten die
unser reporter hannes radweg bekommen
hat wer jetzt vor der psychiatrischen
anstalt ist hannes
genau am montag am ostermontag wurde
gregor es hier in dieser maß an diesem
einrichtung des maßregelvollzugs im
norden von berlin von pflegern in seinem
bett tot aufgefunden zuerst hieß es dass
fremdverschulden ausgeschlossen wurde
dass auch keine anzeichen auf suizid gab
und das offensichtlich auch keine
vorerkrankungen des mörders am sohn des
ehemaligen bundespräsidenten bekannt
waren also alles großes rätselraten dann
meldete sich anonym einen pfleger hier
aus der klinik bei bild und berichtete
von einem wochenlangen hungerstreik in
denen der mörder getreten sein soll wir
haben dann die staatsanwaltschaft
konfrontiert haben gefragt was ist da
los die wollten sich konkret dazu nicht
äußern haben aber explizit auch den
hungerstreik als todesursache nicht
dementiert das wäre allerdings ein fall
der aufgearbeitet werden müsste hannes
bevor wir das einordnen schauen wir noch
mal kurz was vor zweieinhalb jahren
passiert ist ein mord in aller
öffentlichkeit
diese bluttat hat deutschland schockiert
der jüngste sohn des früheren
bundespräsidenten richard von weizsäcker
der mediziner professor fritz von
weizsäcker wird am 19 november 2009 10
durch einen massiven stich in den hals
getötet
der täter gregor s er hat die tat bei
einem vortrag in der schlosspark klinik
berlin penibel geplant spionierte die
familie von weizsäcker über monate aus
sein motiv hass es hat bereits versucht
richard von weizsäcker zu töten in einem
gutachten heißt es damals bei dem
angeklagten sei von der kombinierten
persönlichkeitsstörung
auszugehen im sommer 2020 wird gregor es
dann verurteilt allerdings stellen die
richter eine verminderte schuldfähigkeit
fest der killer bekommt zwar zwölf jahre
wird aber in einer psychiatrischen
einrichtung untergebracht
und hat sich dort also jetzt offenbar zu
tode gehungert alles unter den augen des
staates unter den augen auch von ärzten
ist es ja eine psychiatrie und
verhungern kann man ja nicht von heute
auf morgen
genau der pfleger der eben
offensichtlich auch zugang zu ihm hatte
oder eben auch dessen gesundheitszustand
eben zumindest bekannt war der wusste ja
dass er seit wochen im hungerstreik ist
und interessant ist auch dass während
des prozesses vor zwei jahren 2000 2020
gregor es schon einmal in der
untersuchungshaft in hungerstreik
getreten ist da wollte er eben erwirken
mit diesem dieser zwangsmaßnahme dieser
verweigerung der nahrung dass er in
diesem maßregelvollzug untergebrachten
und er wollte in ein reguläres gefängnis
er wollte hat gesagt ich bin nicht
vermindert schuldfähig ich habe keine
psychische störung ich bin gesund und
deshalb möchte ich eben auch in eine
ganz normale haft hintergrund dessen ist
das eben hier im maßregelvollzug
praktisch die haftzeit nicht angerechnet
wird solange der patient die
inhaftierten gelten eben hier als
patienten eben noch behandelt wird und
solange die hier nicht von den
behandelnden ärzten als gesund entlassen
werden und dann in einer normaler
haftanstalt kommt zählt die zeit
praktisch weiter das heißt hier im
maßregelvollzug kann man wirklich
lebenslang haben und eben nicht nur
diese zwölf jahre die man wegen der
verminderten schuldfähigkeit eben hätte
absitzen lassen müssen du hast
vollkommen recht wir müssen natürlich
der staat muss dafür sorgen dass
inhaftierte in gefängnissen aber eben
auch im maßregelvollzug
gesund bleiben dass sie gesund bleiben
dass sie am leben bleiben und dass ihnen
nichts kein schaden zugefügt wird und
die frage ist die hier sicherlich auch
die justiz dann noch klären muss wie
kann es dazu kommen dass sich jemand
hier in diesem maßregelvollzug in diesem
krankenhaus zu tode hungert und warum
gab es keine zwangsernährung maßnahmen
oder gab es sie vielleicht und warum ist
der patient dann trotzdem gestorben
fragen die noch beantwortet werden
vielen dank für die aktuellen
informationen